Now that we know how
to identify outliers,
the thing we need to do as stated
earlier is check out the outlier values
to see if it's likely that
the data are incorrect.
For example, in our last sample data,
if the age of one of the observations
was 299, then we would be justified
in deciding that this was some
sort of reporting or entry error.
Possibly the correct age was 29 and
an extra 9 was added or
maybe there really was a 99-year old
student attending community college,
and someone mistakenly put a 2
in front of the correct value.
The best course of action in
this case is to try to go back
to the original source to
determine the correct data.
But if that's not possible,
then the best thing to do is to
delete the record from the dataset.
So, what if we don't
have an obvious error and
we aren't certain whether
the data is accurate or not.
If we have a situation such as
the two instances above where it could
be correct, but it's just abnormal,
then the analysis and
modeling process should
include that data.
That said, it is legitimate to
create models without the data as
well to compare results, but
it should be noted which models do and
don't contain the outliers.
Since we're talking about business
analysis, someone within the business
will need to make a decision as
to which model to work with, but
what shouldn't happen is to just drop
the outlying observations just because
it'll be easier to work with.
On the other hand, if like in our first
example, the outlier didn't really
change the results where in our example,
the regression line retained its
original slope, then it can be
legitimate to remove that observation.
Another way that analysts can work
with outliers is called truncation.
This is an instance, for example, where
we know that a certain value can only be
below a given maximum and yet
a value is reported above that.
It might make sense to
keep the observation and
just truncate the value
down to the maximum.
An example of this might be if we were
analyzing training effect of this for
classroom and we knew that the class
could hold only a certain number
of students say, 20 and
you had an observation reported 40.
Here, it might make sense to
change the value to 20 rather than
eliminate the observation entirely.
But keep in mind, anytime those
types of decisions are made,
we should make sure it is noted
in the report of the process.